we've got ourselves a new and studio
guest he is just finishing his rookie
season a tremendous rookie season and he
is definitely in the running for Rookie
Defensive Player of the Year from the
Pittsburgh Steelers I think I see a
couple of Steelers jerseys in our studio
audience here today for Devin Busch good
to see you Devin how are you sir I'm
good how are you
that's good that's an applause line for
everybody why sitting in Florida I felt
like me saying please clap that was a
very Jeb Bush moment right there here it
doesn't show good to see you Devin I do
sir so before we start talking football
Kobe Bryant did he did he resonate with
you at all I mean do you want do you
remember watching him towards the the
end of his playing career I wonder what
you thought about the passing I've been
knowing Kobe says they want just him as
a player a person off the court and I
just I don't know it's hard for me to
believe it right now I don't think I'm
the person that kind of just took it in
yeah I kind of just still believe Kobe
somewhere ahead shooting hoops are
making it a parent somewhere so it
hasn't really sat down with me yet but
just to know that it happened is this
this tragedy you know of course and how
old are you how old are you 21 or 21
yeah so you weren't even born when he
started playing is that a skip all
essentially and that's one of the
reasons why I want to ask you because
you know I'm 50 and I'm you know I know
what it means to me and what he what he
meant playing I mean cuz I saw him from
the very beginning and saw what he made
of himself
I'm wonder what it's like for for a
younger generation to hear about the
passing of Kobe Kobe Oh was in his prime
when it when I was watching him right um
you know coke it was times where I said
YouTube Kobe just to hear him talk know
just about preparation what do you mean
just just interviews I wanted to know
like how was - it was because Kobe was a
person that was like yay look I copied
or I learned from my couture and he
wasn't afraid to say it you know he
wanted to be the best and you've always
seen that you know he's on it I always
had a look in his eyes and the way he
talked it was just always excellence and
everything was always to perfection
they're very detailed so you know been
times where I caught little clips on
YouTube and I just wanted to learn how
to do gotta get to that point so
how old were you when you're going on
YouTube just learning say month trying
to figure 80 somebody okay recently
you're going went online to see how he
was gonna handle his business zeg where
he did handle his business and then how
what did you learn from it what did you
pick up from man uh just just listening
man Kobe was a guy would yeah he was
Kobe he could've do it anything he
wanted to do in the world and everybody
loved him but he always had to focus
about himself you know he's always his
biggest critic and you know he always
wanted to learn how to get better even
when he was at the top he wanted to go
higher than that you know and um he
never was complacent you know he's
always feel like he needed to work with
saw him always need to get better in
certain areas you know depending on
whether it was on or off the field so I
mean he wanted to be a great person and
also want to be a great player and I
think that's something I really want to
do myself
Steelers linebacker Devin Bush here on
the Rich Eisen show so how did you bring
the Mamba mentality to your rookie
season how do you think that work I
stayed like day long you know obviously
was there with everything was new to me
you know just just being a professional
and happy to take care of different
things you know I'm 21 and I got a
mortgage you know so stuff like that I
mean I got to be able to perform and and
come off the field and help my business
and you know it was a lot of
distractions along that way just with
what comes with it and just to be
focusing going every day and knowing
that you know it's a bigger picture in
this yes it's having been around rookies
in the NFL for you know over a decade
and a half it's the idle time the
downtime mm-hmm once you're done when
you're done and being a professional
like lunching out if you will out of
your facility and then what it's been a
lot of guys having an issue with that
yeah once you punch out man is your life
you know you what you do what your life
is what you do and nobody's there to
walk behind you and make sure you're
doing the right thing or the wrong thing
you know every decision you make is what
you want to do so how its Tomlin helped
with that process
he stays yeah you know tom is the type
of guy hey look you guys don't have any
place to eat or you want to come chop it
up my office is here my house is here
you know you put his address up on the
on the big screen to take it down and
you know you come wherever come whenever
talk whenever all I say yep so Tom ones
like here's where I live
put it up on the screen for you and for
the whole team or a team okay well it's
a good thing Antonio Brown wasn't there
to Instagram on that thing I said it's
I'm sorry but you know interestingly
enough did you take him up on that sort
of thing yeah I mean it Bhutan's me and
Tommy talked of course during practice
you know he'll come in the locker room
and walk around a locker room and just
talk to guys you know
he'll catch me in the hallway I catch
them the hallway quick chop it up and
you know just to stay on the right track
and make sure you know my head is on
straight do you know if anybody had
actually rang his Bell at 10 o'clock at
night say hey I'm not sure but I
wouldn't be one of them oh it's just
amazing because I thought this year was
remarkable obviously you were not around
for the final season of Bell and Brown
and obviously the transition what what
did you see in that locker room that
folks were telling you that might have
been different for you um from what I
heard you know Berlin and a B was was
locker room guys everybody loving that
good character you know it's just things
slip away you know from people and um
not I don't know what that what the
issue was or what the with the whole
what started it but all right you know
things kind of got away from from a B
and with a V on Tim - and um when I
walked a lot of room those guys were
super welcoming know they they open arms
me and bro Mia and as a brother
mm-hmm so I mean I don't know what
happened well obviously you're you're
now considering I would imagine
certainly by your play a leader and I'm
wondering what you expect of yourself
and your - from that a big jump maybe we
got to go in the playoffs not too many
times you catch the Pittsburgh Steelers
out of the playoffs you know two years
back to back so we got to get back and
playoffs and we got to continue
Devin Busch here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so if I'm not mistaken week three
you were in San Francisco week three
okay so what can you tell me about this
team that's out there for the NFC it's a
real good team it's the team that plays
together you know offense defense
special teams and they have a great
coaching staff and they believe in what
he said and they believe in this
and they bought in and it goes to show
that they frown on all cylinders playing
great defense plan often setting up
scores you know
blocking punt it do everything so I mean
it's a team where you got to stop them
early and often and make them you know
slow the game down and change the way
they play then again this is week I
think 20 right now in the NFL our week
21 you played him in week 3 what were
the challenges that you think the Chiefs
are gonna face with the scheme that Kyle
Shannon is first 15 script is
particularly evil on defenses what do
you think is the challenge here at a run
game I think San Fran has a really
really good run game in the stats show I
mean all three two running backs got
over six hundred yards on the season and
I just sets them up you know for
everything he opens up the playbook they
could play play play action pass no
total ball deed get the ball quick with
those receivers
listen screen game and at a date they
move it open once once they get a
running game started okay so what you
did not play the Chiefs this year
correctly you did not know
but obviously mahomes is a particular
challenge how do you think he fares
against that defense that that you saw
out on the field against your teammates
home is gonna do Holmes do regardless of
the fact but I think it's the San Fran's
job to contain that you know he's gonna
make some good throws of course tire
you're gonna touch the ball early and
off there but I think once you limit
that team and you you got to get a stop
you can't let that team keep driving
down the field to keep scoring or they
get a good rhythm going and they're hard
to beat so I mean it depends on you know
who's gonna make the first crucial stop
or who's gonna have a devious a
touchdown that you know make the game
that much more hard to win all right
Devin Bush so before I let you go into
that Miami day who do you have winning
this Super Bowl this weekend San
Francisco okay is that because you don't
play the Chiefs next year you already
know that and I just I got a good
feeling they are they they say hi right
now and I think they focused as a team
you can see they're not it'll take
anybody lightly you know they may had a
game where they started slow but once
they start they they are
okay well Frank Clark fella Michigan man
would probably disagree with you
immensely right here and he's been um
he's been walking it after talking it
quite a bit he says or he's walked it
and then he's talked it missing a minute
no what is that right yeah okay you know
that I do blow that it's good to see you
Devin Bush loved having you on NFL
gameday morning a couple of weeks ago
and I love having you here on this show
when you're out Los Angeles love to have
you out my studio over there have a good
day here in your native Florida right
yeah yes at Stefan but everybody right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app